hey you look stressed yeah I'm trying to
migrate to the cloud but I also have to
come up with this encryption strategy
like I don't have time for this ever -
got my hands full okay well I have some
good news with Google we'll move into
the cloud why she'd give you encryption
by default encryption by default can you
show me how that works
sure thing let's take a look
encryption at arrests is central to our
security strategy and there are several
options based on customer security needs
by default data arrest is encrypted in
all Google cloud platform products force
requests of data or where you have a
requirement to manager encryption key
we have customers the option imagine
during keys using customer monitoring
keys or cement for short
using a managed service called cloud kms
then for small percentage of workloads
there may be a requirement to generate
your own krypton key or manager
on-premise and for that we provide the
option to use customer support
encryption keys or SESAC for short let's
see how it works
by default when I upload a file to cloud
storage it will automatically be
encrypted and rest
with Google manage keys as we can see
here this is transparent to the user but
a lot happens behind the scenes data
spread into chunks and each chunk is
encrypted with a unique bid encryption
key then these day encryption keys are
encrypted with their own key encryption
keys stored in Google's kms the data
chunks are then distributed across
Google storage systems and replicated an
encrypted form for backup and disaster
recovery and this happens your real-time
all by default and transparent to the
user well that's a relief
but like I still have to manage our key
rotation policies and I've got keys that
I have to do Hardware backed encryption
for what am I supposed to do about that
no worries
look at all that to let me show you how
sure cloud kms is a host at key
management service that lets you manage
crypto keys
free cloud services similar to the way
you would do it on premise it's also
integrated into cloud I am and
cataloging so you can manage permissions
and individual keys and monitor how
they're used we'll start by creating a
new keyring
first we name it then we can choose
location like make global however the
ring location matters based on where my
resources are I'm going to pick you as
central as that's where my workloads are
now I create my key first like I specify
the key name then each key has a purpose
which defines the cryptographic
capabilities of the key I'm going to
choose to use this to do symmetric
encrypt or decrypt I can then choose if
there's a software or hardware backed if
there's a requirement to use Hardware we
can use HSM Cloud HSM is a cult hosted
hardware security module service that
allows you to host encryption keys in
perform cryptographic operations in a
cluster of FIPS 140 - to level 3
certified HSMs all managed by Google for
you next I can specify the rotation
period which is the time between when
the new key versions are generated
automatically now let's say I want to go
ahead and use our encryption VHS M and
make the rotation period 3 days and
click create let's go back to our
storage bucket example I can create a
new bucket and configure it to use my
new custom amount encryption key
policies I give it a name region is
still US central with my keys and HSMs
and now I can change the encryption
options from Google manage key to
customer manage key
so as I do that my keyring and keys pop
up and I can choose which one to use
lastly I need to authorize a service
account to perform encrypt and decrypt
operations with the key I just selected
granted now when I upload a file whether
it's a few kilobytes or a few petabytes
I'll be encrypted using my key
so let's upload a file called super
important file and you can see it's
indeed using custom managed keys and is
the actual key I selected when I click
on it I can open it now let's go back to
my keys the whole point of C Mac using
kms is give customers control order key
policies so let's say I want to go and
now disable that key once I disabled it
all do not immediately I will no longer
be able to access the file let's try it
soft Ricky's been disabled I try to open
the file I can see that I can no longer
access it and the error I get is that
colic AMS has been disabled or destroyed
and the kms UI I can see that the key I
was using was indeed disabled that's
what we mean by custom ouch keys Wow
so now I have the option to choose what
encryption strategy makes sense for me
and I can mix and match for different
parts of my cloud migration that's right
encryption is a complex topic so we work
really hard to make sure the full
complexity is abstracted away that way
you get the best innovations and control
we need it don't forget to Like comment
and subscribe for more great Google
cloud platform content
[Music]